I'm a mom of two and I saw Despicable Me
3 with my two kids who are ages 11 and
13. here's my bottom line positive
themes yes working together family good
versus evil being a new stepmom not
knowing what to do that's all in there
violence and scare Factor the bad guy in
this movie is more comical I would say
than scary he wears a purple jumpsuit
from the 80s he has a mustache and a
mullet sex and romance there's there's
no sex or really romance in this movie
besides Lucy and Guru being married and
as far as anything else is concerned
it's really more the brother's
relationship that we're focusing on in
this category and bad language none so
my kids are a little bit older and they
were older than a lot of the kids in the
audience but they still really enjoyed
it and I watched them laugh out loud
which is always relieving to me when I
take them to a film I think parents are
really going to enjoy this new villain
Balthazar brat he is this former 80s
child star that's still obsessed with
his character on this short-lived hit TV
show and you know he wears the purple
jumpsuit with the shoulder pads he's got
the pump sneakers and he does retro
dance battles I won't tell you the songs
but moms and dads you will love the 80s
music in this film as a mom I always
appreciate the depiction of these
daughters in this franchise because even
though one of them now is going into her
teenage years and more into electronics
and less into family Chit Chat they
never depict them as being bratty which
I appreciate and I think there's enough
of on TV and don't forget the minions
which is why a lot of the kids are going
to this movie anything that's scary at
all for small children is lightened
right up by these cute little creatures
this movie is fast-paced but it's fun
it's funny and it's just as harmless as
a movie can be Despicable Me 3 is rated
PG and I think it's good for kids of all
ages that's your mom's movie minute
thanks for watching and if you you have
any questions or comments you can leave
them below we'll see you next time bad
language I would say zero as far as I
could remove it I love when he tries to
sell things and he's going through like
puberty was breaking out